[Musique]
faire du ski à quelques minutes de Paris
c'est possible sur l'île des
Impressionnistes de Chatou je me trouve
actuellement au parc alpin à côté 2100
ce qui raclette ou encore patinoire
venait découvrir avec moi ces nombreux
activités
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement avec Céline
Caillat directrice de la communication
et marketing de ce superbe endroit alpin
du coup village alpin qu'est ce que
c'est un petit peu ce que vous pouvez me
présenter du coup qu'est-ce qu'on y
trouve la première station d'hiver de
l'Ouest parisien on y trouve trois sites
dans un site on a une piste de luge une
piste de ski avec biathlon une piste de
ski alpin et une grande patinoire de 500
mètres carrés le parc afterwork avec
trois bars et des DJ à partir de 17
heures le soir et la troisième partie
qui est le domaine de la restauration
avec 150 télécabines et plus de 10
téléphériques qui vont de 8 à 16
personnes dont 11 heures le matin à
23h30
on peut venir déjeuner à partir de 11
heures le matin et toute la journée
c'est un service continu en télécabine
et le soir à partir de 19h en télécabine
pour fondue et raclette c'est vraiment
l'ambiance du ski avec les produits
savoyard un grand sourcing savoyard tous
les produits viennent de savoir et c'est
pour tout public et c'est pour tout
public loin des tout-petits c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 5 ans et on
fait un droit d'entrée mais qu'on
appelle le Pass entré de 10 euros mais
qui a un bon de consommation c'est pas
une vraie entrée c'est vraiment pour
consommer sur place pour avoir droit à
une attraction à des crêpes et chocolats
chauds et du coup pour la patinoire pour
la consommation d'énergie aussi des
télécabines comment vous avez un petit
peu aménagé ça fait 500 mètres carrés
oui de patinoire un travail avec une
très belle société qui s'appelle
cinerglass où la consommation d'énergie
équivaut à trois foyers de 4 personnes
sur un mois et surtout en tel cabine on
a retiré tous les chauffages qui étaient
présents dans les télécabines les 150
télécabines n'ont pas de chauffage c'est
pour ça qu'on demande nos clients de
jouer le jeu de venir en tenue de ski et
puis on fournit les plaids tous les
jours et le vin chaud moi ça m'a donné
envie en tout cas je ne sais pas où mais
moi je vais aller tester ces activités
bonjour est-ce que ce serait possible de
faire du patin s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un petit passage par la piste de luge de
plus de 4 mètres de haut et 25 mètres de
long
puis je me suis rendu sur la piste de
ski un tapis roulant en revêtement
synthétique qui permet de s'initier ou
de retrouver des sensations
après l'effort le réconfort en
télécabine avec une carte savoyarde
appétissante ce sera fondue à la truffe
pour cette fois-ci
si vous n'avez pas la chance de partir
au sport d'hiver à la montagne pas de
panique vous pouvez venir vous initier
ou pratiquer ici jusqu'au 29 janvier
prochain